where do we start with Becky because
she's quite the character right
she's a combination of
all those gals out there and I'm not
gonna
Proclaim that this is all women this is
a good chunk of women out there this is
probably about two-thirds
of the dating pool over the age of 27 to
30 let's say
which happens to be the main demographic
the guys that watch you know my videos
so yes strap in bomber command is going
to is going to be taking some Flack for
this one but we're also going to be
dropping some cold hard truth bombs
I'm just going to read basically
straight from the chapter I'm not going
to give you the whole chapter and of
course this is going to get some edits
before it gets uh finalized Uh Kevin
from sales is also doing the uh edit for
this book again I thought he did a great
job with the first book so we've heard
him again for the second book
let's get right into it
so
Becky today's modern woman the term
Modern Woman has been thrown around a
lot
now that women are getting degrees high
paying professions buying homes paying
more taxes and are strong and
independent I didn't put in quotes but
I'm going to do that for the video let's
call her Becky in this chapter Becky's
older than 27 and she's a working
professional
I've dated a lot of Becky's
again name's not always Becky could be
Rebecca it could be Jennifer it could be
Chris could be Christina could be Kathy
could be
Terry could be whatever you know you
know you know all the names
so at no time in history did so many
women ever parrot the phrase I don't
need no man or a woman needs a man like
a fish needs a bicycle but today it is
very very common
okay
women are earning more degrees than ever
before in fact in colleges and
universities women outnumber Men by a
large margin in large Urban cities Becky
is everywhere she is a very common
Avatar my friends
she's far more common than the
traditional woman that wants to be
protected and provided for by a strong
virtuous man as a mother and a wife
Becky is the type of woman that uses
hashtags like boss girl or hashtag boss
babe and her Instagram post
look at my phone handy let's just do a
quick
quick search and see what comes up I'm
always I'm always curious
let's do boss girl first hashtag
see what we get up
there are 869
000 posts
and then what was the other one boss
babe
oh my God yeah there's five million
and then it starts to show you accounts
like MILF boss babe
um anyway so this is this is Becky's
typical day she Becky gets up in the
morning usually as her fur babies jump
on her bed as the alarm goes off looking
to be fat and taken out for a walk she
makes her bed a line 17 decorative
pillows in just the right fashion yes
that's correct Becky has
not two not four but 17 decorative
pillows you've all been over to replace
she has her coffee and Scrolls through
her screen she catches up on her
horoscope
favorite group chats with her family
friends and comments on how much she
loves them all her nieces her nephews
and godchildren she Praises everyone in
the group in the chat and there's also
dispense pictures of cute little Sally
doing something simple like wiping her
own bum
of course Becky comments
foreign
she then goes on to read messages from
several men that she's ignored that have
reached out to her while she was asleep
telling her how pretty she is calling
her a queen then messages a lot of men
that have ignored her with good morning
handsome messages desperately hoping one
of them will reach out for another date
after they hooked up and went silent on
her
Alpha seed beta need right in that
little paragraph
Becky then takes a shower puts on her
power suit with padded shoulders that
admires her degree for a moment framed
in Mahogany
sometimes I bet Becky wishes she was
made out of mahogany
there's little letters after her name
reminding her that she is important
she then scans around her home and
admires her Decor selections and reminds
herself she is strong and independent
with a total boss baby she is and how
lucky a guy would be to be with her
sorry I gotta have to I might have to
drink and spray my throat a few times
during this
you guys enjoying this so far you guys
let me know in the chat
carrying on she then says goodbye to her
fur babies and her best baby voice you
ever notice that they're not like large
dogs like a dog that looks like it could
rip off your arm and beat you with it
sort of thing they're always like little
white fluffy inbred sort of weird dogs
that Yap at everything
anyway she says goodbye to her fur
babies and her best baby voice and
commutes to work to smash the patriarchy
Often by serving male-owned corporations
Becky doesn't see the irony of not
wanting to serve a husband and family at
home but is okay with serving a man at
work and paying taxes to the state
after a long day of Smashing the
patriarchy working for the man
Becky now finds time to fill one of her
rotating weekly Hobbies drinking with
her other strong and independent friends
maybe having workouts or a dinner or
returning some Decor that she bought
that didn't fit her style maybe spending
some time at work to climb that
corporate ladder
slaving away at the machine to pay more
taxes and be an even bigger boss babe
by the time Becky gets home she often
finds that the loves of her life the fur
babies have either vomited or defecated
in her home somewhere
after cleaning up the mess and talking
sorry and taking the fur babies out for
a walk while loudly talking on her phone
in public to her mom or sister or BFF
about how important her day was smashing
the patriarchy she returns home to fix a
salad sits on her couch swiping on
dating apps looking for her equal
partner
disgusted by her options wondering where
all the good men have gone and talking
to several men completely out of her
League hoping one of them will be her
knight in shining armor and eventually
be her soul mate although you know they
mostly ignore
what Becky fails to understand is that
she has no prize she's Pastor Prime she
spent her early 20s partying drinking
smoking and doing too many drugs she
slept with so many men she's forgotten
half of them and when somebody asks what
her Notch count is she only remembers
the men that she was in longer term
relationships with but forgot the names
of most of the people she had one night
stands with was friends with benefits
with had threesomes gave BJs to or had
lesbian encounters with
Becky accepts that she is incredibly
interested in a man's future to provide
for her burning desire for a family and
children
but is unable to see that men of value
aren't particularly concerned with her
future but very concerned about her past
and baggage she doesn't see but
nevertheless brings to the table you see
one of Becky's biggest conundrums was
that she was sold the feminist lie of
the strong independent woman but she
also painfully feels the ticking of her
biological clock and Counting every egg
that isn't being fertilized monthly
while watching her friends and family
have babies
I'm not sure how much of this chapter
I'm going to re probably going to get
through another page and then I want to
share a really interesting article that
completely aligns with this Becky thing
that I literally just got 20 minutes
before I sat down here to get ready for
the show it's it's it's perfect
perfectly timed
how's the audio by the way in the
good looks good mutes
um yeah yeah moff is in there so make
sure you stay in the waiting room for
the Q a section moth will be screening
you guys out we'll probably get to the Q
a in like 15-20 minutes so just stand by
all right moving on so Becky is
delusional Becky's expectations are so
incredibly High only a handful of men
could meet her requirements yet every
Becky has nearly the same expectation
when men are what she brings to the team
tells them she is smart she is funny
she's educated has her own place a car
and a career
what Becky doesn't understand is that
she's describing a man and what makes
him attractive
setting aside or confusion around what
she thinks men wants just a lot of the
red flags I mentioned in my first book
like debt large Dodge count is
disagreeable and bossy feminist not fit
obsessed with Decor masculine has
tasteless tattoos can often be a single
mother and sometimes brings multiple
children from multiple fathers I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out